one of the most engrossing and creative
shows on any streaming platform one
division is a crowd pleaser even for
people new to the mcu
if you want to learn about the magic
behind this marvel series then prepare
for the untold truth of wandavision
marvel studios has been dominating
television for decades
dating back to the days of the 1960s
spider-man cartoon and bill bixby's the
incredible hulk it's been more common to
see the spandex clad marvel characters
on a small screen than it has been to
see them on the big screen
but until wandavision those tv shows
didn't hail from marvel studios the
outfit responsible for the movies in the
marvel cinematic universe for decades
marvel licensed their characters in film
and television out to other studios
that all changed in 2010 when marvel
started their own standalone division
marvel television to tackle small screen
outings for their characters
the likes of agents of shield and
daredevil were just a few instances of
the shows produced by marvel television
but despite scoring a number of
successes marvel television was shut
down in 2019
resulting in the demise of countless
popular programs as well as an unmade
animated howard the duck series
sometimes i still get this feeling
there's some kind of special destiny
waiting for me
the seismic shift was due to the
company's new focus on marvel studios
produced television programs made
specifically for the disney plus
streaming service
the first show in that initiative
wandavision the first in a new era of
marvel television
over the course of one division a
grown-up monica rambo has become a fan
favorite character particularly once she
got her superpowers in the show's
seventh episode
in addition to being entertaining rambo
has also become someone who's proven
important to the overall plot of
wandavision
in particular her internal struggle with
missing the death of her mom
has served as an effective parallel to
wanda maximoff's own struggle with grief
rambo is a manifestation of hope that
wanda can work through her own pain
that there is a path to coping beyond
just getting lost in sitcoms
given her central role it can be
surprising to realize that rambo wasn't
always supposed to appear in one
division when show runner jack shaper
first pitched the series monaco was
nowhere to be
seen shafer explained to screen rant
there was a character like monica she
served the purpose of monica and my
pitch
but it was a later discovery that we
could use monica rambo for that
character and that was so exciting when
we put those pieces together
monica rambo may not have always been a
part of wandavision but viewers
everywhere would agree that it's now
impossible to imagine the show without
her
wandavision wouldn't be a classic sitcom
if it wasn't at least partially filmed
in front of a live studio audience
while later episodes of the show would
employ an artificial laugh track the
real thing was sometimes used as well
producers decided to film one division's
debut episode which evoked sitcoms to
the 1950s in front of actual people
needless to say capturing wanda maximoff
and vision on a small stage in front of
an audience was a massive departure from
the traditional filming style of mcu
properties but filming the show in this
manner didn't just add further
authenticity to the retro vibe of
wandavision's earliest episodes
it also brought out the best in the
actors themselves as one of the audience
members one division lead tiana paris
can attest
as paris explained to tv line i got to
take a little cheat day and absorb it
all and watch my amazing cast mates
lizzie olson and paul bettany and
catherine han
kill it and then i jumped in with them a
little later
kat dennings entered the marvel
cinematic universe in the franchise's
fourth entry the first thor movie
playing the role of jane foster's intern
darcy lewis dennings provided levity as
an original character created for the
mcu
she reprised the role in thor the dark
world where she now had her own intern
but that was the end of her story
at least for a moment she subsequently
vanished from the series and it wasn't
hard to see why
the next thor movie ragnarok was mostly
set in places other than earth
and more importantly it depicted thor
and foster as having broken up
thus giving foster's intern no reason to
appear it appeared the book was closed
on darcy and that perception wasn't just
shared by fans
apparently until one division came along
dennings was convinced that there
wouldn't be any further opportunities
for her to appear in the series
thening said to entertainment weekly
that call was very unexpected
of course i was delighted to be asked i
am just a big fan of marvel in general i
had no expectations of ever coming back
so i was just thrilled
1950s 1960s and now the 70s
why does it keep switching time periods
it can't be purely for my enjoyment can
it
the marvel cinematic universe couldn't
be brought to life without the talents
of many artists but there's no denying
that marvel studios chief creative
officer kevin feige is a key creative
voice in the sprawling enterprise
his influence was particularly felt with
wand division as he came up with the
initial concept of creating a sitcom
that would take the characters of juan
to maximoff and vision and plot them
into suburbia
not only was feige taking cues from
earlier comic runs featuring the two
characters namely house of m and the
vision he was also inspired by his own
love of sitcoms
feige was apparently a naked knight fan
growing up and that love has seeped into
his creative pursuits at marvel studios
watching wandavision it becomes readily
apparent which tv shows certain episodes
take cues from
the first episode wears its love for the
dick van dyke show in its sleeve
while a later episode features the
staircase that could only have come from
the brady punch
however movies have also provided
creative inspiration for the production
and talking about how the series tackled
unique visual traits
one division director matt shakman
revealed that two films from the 90s had
a great deal of influence on this marvel
tv show
when asked if pleasantville and the
truman show had any sort of impact on
wandavision jackman told the hollywood
reporter
absolutely i love both of them i think
that there's some spiritual connection
to both films of course
pleasantville also explored black and
white 1950s sitcoms but with an eerie
touch that emphasized how divorced from
reality these programs were
what's more pleasantville and wanovision
share a prop designer russell bobbitt
who helped ensure that both projects got
the tiniest details of their tv worlds
just right
pop quiz wonder how does a housewife get
a blood stain out of white linen
by doing it herself the mcu may be a pop
culture juggernaut but even it couldn't
avoid being impacted by the covet 19
pandemic
every project in the works at marvel
studios was delayed by the crisis with
their entire movie schedule getting
delayed over a year
wandavision was no exception the show
was almost four months into filming
before principal photography was shut
down
as recalled by director matt shakman to
the hollywood reporter
the timing on this whole matter was
peculiar shakman explained
we were shut down on a really
interesting moment because we had just
wrapped in atlanta and we had moved to
la
so we were about ready to start shooting
the next chunk of our schedule which was
all about shooting on backlots
principal photography took months to
resume only kicking in once more in fall
2020 albeit with extensive new safety
procedures in place
wandavision employs a number of visual
tricks that help clarify the differences
between the sitcom world inside the hex
and the real world outside
beyond the use of period-era costumes
and black and white photography one
notable visual trait is the show's ever
shifting aspect ratios
the show is known for sometimes making
these changes right in the middle of a
scene
different aspect ratios such as 4x3 are
used for the different eras of
television that take place inside the
hex
the on-screen visuals are bending to the
history of classic television as a way
of reflecting how much control wanda has
over her reality
meanwhile a two point forty by one
aspect ratio is used for scenes that are
supposed to remind the viewer that
they're watching something firmly rooted
in reality such as everything happening
at sword's compound or in agatha's
basement
the marvel cinematic universe has
tackled period projects before with
films like captain america the first
avenger and captain marvel
but wandavision was multiple period
pieces in one requiring the team to
focus on endless details from different
arrows
matt shakman explained the process to
the hollywood reporter
we recreated everything from vintage
lenses production and costume design to
the actors getting together with me and
studying what those old shows looked
like
we tried to put our finger on what
comedy was like back in the 50s versus
the 60s because it really does change
it was really important because
ultimately this is the reality of that
episode and we wanted people to fully
buy into it
going the extra mile in every department
they even brought in a dialect coach to
nail the voices of each decade paid off
rather than just doing surface level
pastiche wandavision took the mcu period
piece to a new level but i am doing my
best to blend in
wanovision has been praised for its
ability to go weird and creepy without
winking to the audience
it's a tone that hasn't really been
explored in previous marvel cinematic
universe properties which have largely
avoided eeriness
though it's widely seen as a
groundbreaking trait of the program one
division showrunner jack shaper doesn't
see the program's aesthetic as totally
unprecedented in fact she's attributed
the show's unique vibe to a prior
creative endeavor in the mcu
thor ragnarok like wandavision ragnarok
was widely praised for its distinctive
weirdness
things like a kindly kiwi rock monster
or an ending where asgard needed to be
destroyed weren't standard mcu fixtures
instead they reflected the bold creative
spirit of writer director taika ytt
these creative inventions inspired
shafer who told indy wire
that was really the movie for me that
broke my brain i thought it was just so
daring and so exciting
smashing the mold and taking all the
colors and throwing them around
by the end of avengers infinity war
vision hasn't just ended up dead he's
had his head ripped open by thanos
it's a gruesome moment that seemed to
put an end to vision especially after
the character didn't return for the big
blowout adventure in avengers end game
even vision actor paul bettany never
thought he'd get to play the character
again
let alone is one of the lead characters
of a big tv show
therefore bettany didn't know what to
expect at his meeting with marvel execs
telling emmy
i was called in to see kevin feige and
marvel co-president luis esposito and
was convinced that they were going to be
gentlemen and say
it's been a great ride thank you for
your work and good luck that of course
isn't what happened and once betney was
informed of what the future held for
vision
he jumped at the chance to reinhabit the
character when one division was first
announced at san diego comic-con it was
also revealed that elizabeth olson would
be reprising her role as wanda maximoff
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
while it wasn't clear what kind of parts
she'd play in that blockbuster since
that announcement
it's been apparent that wandavision
would be helping to establish dr
strange's second solo adventure
however it now appears that it's not the
only upcoming mcu movie the show is
helping to set up
in an interview with comicbook.com one
division director matt
shakman revealed that he'd been
coordinating with other mcu productions
to make sure his tv series fit into the
larger mcu canvas
two mcu directors he'd been in
particularly close contact with were
multiverse of madnesses sam raimi
and spider-man no way home director john
watts shackman put it now because you
know it's
it's a it's a relay race this whole
thing and so you're passing the baton
and you want to make sure that that is
that hand-off is is
effortless and and perfect right given
that no cast members from no way home
have appeared in one division thus far
it's currently unclear how it connects
to the next spider-man movie
perhaps it'll connect by way of those
rumored multiverse shenanigans a web
crawler will supposedly engage in
whatever the connection ends up being
it's just one of numerous ways
wandavision is connected to the larger
mcu
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you